*Game noises*
OH FUCK YOU! OKAY! FUCK OFF!
*Darkiplier with a weird accent* I had technical difficulties but they've all been solved now! >:)
*Evil laugh* (Mark is possessed, some call Sam and Dean)
*cough cough cough*
Enough lollygagging, enough silly bitchery
*Possessed Darkiplier* LET'S GET TO THE GAME
Pull the blue trigger to turn your flashlight ON!
Okay... do I want to?
Oh God I thought there was going to be something behind me
Ha-boink! *Sound of flashlight turning on*
*Girl's laugh in-game*
OOOH! Oh, okay! [Momentary Pause] HII!
How you doin'?
Oh that's lovely. OOH that's delightful! *sarcastic*
What else is gonna pop up in front of me?
Okay. Hello everybody my name is Markiplier- you still over there?
You'd better be. You'd better b- *sudden realization that there's an audience* oh. HI EVERYBODY! My name is Markiplier and welcome to the Sisters demo.
Now this is a uh, indie horror game that's comin' out on the VIVE
I don't know when but this is just a demo
And um, there aren't a lot of uh, horror games out for the vive right now
So it's kinda slim pickings but this one seems to be pretty decent even though there wasn't a lot of information on it
because it's not fully released there's no revieeewws
Hello. OH. Ooh! Hi! OOOAH! Oh this is lovely!
Very Victorian
Eugh. Very spoopy! Oh hi. Oh hi. *Laughs nervously* How you doin'?
Oh are you looking at me?
YOU'D BETTER NOT BE FOLLOWING ME... Okay you're not following me.
Oh hi.
What th- HEY! HEY WAIT A MINUTE. OOH, you silly little girl! You're lucky you're on the other side of MY WALL HERE
Or else I'd be comin' after you
Are you right where the camera is? Holy shit you're pretty close to where the camera is
HIIII!
So you've... when I... Oooh- Woah, what just happened there?
I had a sensor problem there! It made me very disoriented
Okay. Wait I don't have my other thing! There it is, *Thunder* I don't wanna step on it
Hokay. Hi lady! Jesus Christ! Hellooo
Can I help you? Can I help you sir?
*Little girl singing in-game*
Okay, that's- No thank you, I've had enough, I'm okay, I've got enough girl scout cookies, *Thunder* I'm alright
Okay, so...
UUUMM
Also, this game was a little bit restrictive
because it required a rum-sized scale so I needed to make sure my room was wide enough-
DON'T DO THAT!
OOAH, DON'T DO THAT! *Bang* Fuck you!
WHAT DID I DO
OH, I PANIC PAUSED
Hello. Hi. Hang on a second
What the fuck
What's under the tarp?
What's under you?
Oooh, where'd she go
Where did the little girl go
Hi...
''Electronics: Do and Dont's'' *Thunder*
Probab... Oh my god
What is that?
Something is going on there
Wait... *Thunder* Something is not right
Hello...
Oh jeez
She got bigger. She wasn't like that before, was she?
Hi...
Uuh...
I kept thinking it was gonna pop out at me
She looked a little different
it's like...
Uuh, I don't like that
I don't like that...
It's like following me... I don't know, whatever
Okay, hello
Hi!
[creepy girl laughing] STOP THAT... FUCK YOU! *Thunder*
DON'T DO IT
Oooh, don't you do it... You little girl
YOU LOVELY LITTLE GIRL!
AND YOUR LOVELY... *Thunder* I don't wanna give you a hug
That's just what you... What is happening?
Why is that... Ah shit!
OH. Hi.
Oh, you've gotten bigger...
Oh, look how big you've grown...
*Thunder* Oooh, you sweet little bloody-eyed girl!
Oh how much I love you
Shut the. *Wooden Bang* FUCK UP!... OH, HI!
OH, FUCK YOU... OK, FUCK OFF!
FUCK YOU!
What is... WHAT, THAT'S IT!?
[Frustrated Silence]
I just had my life dicked with me for like two minutes!
And you're gonna pull THAT shit on ME?!
*Game Music Playing*
You just gonna end it...
*hmpf*
Man...
I didn't even read what was on the book
Huhh
Where are you guys? *OVER HERE MARK*
Ah shit. Goddammit!
I didn't even get to brag about my awesome setup >:(
I'm gonna go back in, because I don't think I saw everything
Good God...
What the fuck happened?
Alright, I'm coming back into it
And this time, I'm gonna actually look. I'm gonna actually get a chance to take in the environment
Instead of being distracted the whole time
So now... We're gonna pay very close attention to what is going on around me
Hi!
I'm gonna be right with you
I've gotta look around, because there's a lot of stuff going on here, *Thunder* so
Okay, so that's the beginning. It wasn't even looking at me
Okay that's nice... What's back there?
There's something back there
Okay there's something over here. There's a lot of stuff
Hang on, I'll be right with you...
You crazy little girl *Thunder*
Some weird thing covered in a drape... and a book
Can I... [fighting noises]
I'm gonna beat the shit outta you! *Thunder*
You get over here! Awh, you're lucky...
Ah. Oh wait. How close am I to something?
*boinkiedieboink*
So everything's fine
... so far *Thunder*
Stop looking at me
Aaah, shit!
Any... Goddamn... min- *Noise* Oh fuck off with that!
Ah shit...
Where'd you go little girl? *Thunder*
Where'd you go?...
Hi, okay. Open the book
Ok. Alright. [reads] "She will never let me be happ-" Fu-what was that?!
"She was there in the library"... Fucking stop!
"She knew I would be the one to find her there, I always found her" *Thunder*
"She was not happy..." [little girl crying] Shut up!
''... that I was his favorite. He should have loved us the same...'
"This way we will never be apart again. She will always be there, looking over my shoulder, *Thunder* and he will love us both."
HI! ... [shouts] Oh, give your daddy a big hug!! ... HI!
How you doing? [smooch]
You want a little smooch? [smooch]
Oh you're such a pretty little princess...
Let me... Bat your head in with a flashlight!
Ah shit, she's after me
Ah. *Bang* OH, HEY!
Oh okay. AH IT'S COMING... FUCK YOU!
WHERE YOU AT?
FUUUUCK OFF!
I'm waiting...
[Creaking sounds]
Okay...
[More creaking sounds]
Hello?... AH FUCK YOU... FUCK OFF!
THE FUCK OUTTA HERE!
GET THE FUCK OUTTA HERE!
Okay, alright...
So we've finally read what we we're supposed to play
So anyway, that was very short, but that was still very good!
I liked that! Why is it so short... Why are the good ones always so SHORRTT!
Aah, man. It's good though, it's really good
But either way, thank you everybody so much for watching
I am sorry it's so short, but I can't wait for the full version for this to come out
Because I kinda love the whole idea of like a room- exploration style game
And I think I, uh. I remember I found a game on Vive that actually was like a room escape type of deal
So I might play that in the future [outro music starts playing]
But thank you everybody so much for watching. Let me know what you thought of this down in the comments below...
And as always... I will see you... In the next video
BUH BYE!
[Top Video] [Shouts] AHHH! FUCK YOU! What the Fuck!
Ok Fuck Off!
[Bottom Video] *Exaggerated Smooching Sound* How about a little of that? ill kiss your giant nose
Oh. Float like a butterfly, Kiss like a bee. *Exaggerated Smooching Noise*